[Music]
we decide to commit to a new Energy
System if we do not signal the terminal
decline of the fossil fuel era as we
know it we welcome our own terminal
decline another climate change
conference another Global Shakedown yeah
there are a lot of noxious emissions
emerging from the first day of the cop
28 conference
Dubai all know that a key success factor
across climate agenda is finance let
this be the year that climate
Finance meets the magnitude of the
moment now let me translate this for you
the elites who flew in on their Gulf
Stream 550s are demanding that affluent
Nations Pony up big to the Nations that
are supposedly struggling to deal with
the effects of global warming oh do we
still call it that but let's call this
what it is green extortion or climate
reparations yes that's a thing and who
better to lead the charge than a guy who
flies private after he married the Widow
of the Hines Fortune we're very much
committed now to work with our Congress
to provide $ 17.5 million specifically
towards the fund for climate impacts
response an additional $4.5 million for
the Pacific resilience facility another
25 million for the Santiago Network why
doesn't Teresa pay it I mean they have
the money now of course the big
polluters with massive populations India
and China they have no intention of
phasing out coal or oil or gas but
they're happy to humor the FL climate
fat cats who gather annually to make
each other feel better by throwing some
money into the climate pot joining me
now is n gangri former Speaker of the
House in Fox News contributor new it's
just a thing to behold it's it seems to
happen annually but for me it seems to
happen every week uh Biden is sending
comma to rep the green agenda in this
case she gets all the fun assignments
doesn't she
n well look I think that the left is
deeply committed to taking your money
spending it on their friends I mean
think about the irony you go to the
Middle East the center of producing oil
and gas in order to have a conference
about why you shouldn't produce oil and
gas and they're good enough that they
say it with a straight face I mean this
is you know an amazing Broadway show
which goes all over the world uh playing
from place to place it's John Cary
flying in to the next five star hotel to
go to the next Gourmet restaurant in
order to be deeply worried at which
point he has to go back get on his plane
to go to the next fstar hotel to the
next Gourmet restaurant to be even more
worried this whole thing is an Elite
ripoff of everyday workers and that's
why you're seeing in Argentina in
Holland and Italy and across the planet
a move towards the right from people who
have been realized they're the ones
paying you when John krey talks about
giving away money guess what that's your
money John K's cheerful about taking
money from you to give to these people
he's never met who will then by the way
mostly squander it it won't achieve
anything uh it's it's an absurdity and
historians will someday look back and
say how could they have been so stupid
for so long now the un's climate change
secretary new I think revealed what's
really going on here
watch if this transition isn't
just we won't transition at all and that
means Justice within and between
countries sharing benefits across
Society ensuring that everyone in all
their
diversity have equal opportunities to
benefit from these transitions he has
the inflection in gesticulation of any
random dictator but new um isn't this
just it's just a redistribution of
wealth scheme right America's too rich
America is too wealthy spread the wealth
around the rest of the world Simon
doesn't care about global global warming
or climate
change it's worse than just a
redistribution because they want to skim
off the top to take care of their
friends if we had a list of every Green
energy project the US government has
funded which has failed totally and then
said well where did the money go cindra
you'll find virtually all of them are
donors to the Democratic party yeah
these they're all they're all buddies
this whole thing is a rig game hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else